[Music]
all about my God
did you remember
[Music]
regardless of where you look or in what
time period you look you'll find that
humans are always making music and the
music that we make is similar in certain
ways too and this sort of thing might
seem obvious to us just because it's
what we're used to already but when we
see this kind of global pattern it
suggests that there's something in our
biology and in how we humans have
evolved that makes it so commonplace in
the world so if some song types like
lullabies are grounded in human biology
and evolution does that mean that they
can then transcend cultural and
linguistic barriers and if that's the
case other types of human songs a
universal language so to test this
question what we did is we put together
a large Archive of 118 recordings of
songs recorded all around the world they
were used as dance songs lullabies
healing songs and love songs in their
original locations and we recorded these
songs from 86 different societies around
the globe so a really diverse set of
musical simulink and then we took these
songs and played them to an equally
diverse group of participants so we have
around 6 000 people from 49
industrialized societies and three
relatively isolated societies and so in
total we have about 31 languages that
these people are speaking so this is a
really diverse representative group of
people and we asked all of these
participants to listen to each of the
songs and choose what context that they
thought the song was originally used in
and what we found when we analyzed the
data that we had was that regardless of
where in the world these participants
were from or what language they spoke
participants were able to identify dance
songs lullabies and healing songs all
out above chance levels we in our lab
think that it's because music probably
evolved around two main functions one
would be in the context of soothing
babies because a song is such an honest
signal of you actually attending to them
and showing you that showing them that
you care right so lullabies may have
developed as a really honest signal of
affection and being there for your
children so we think that's one way that
music may have developed but we also
think that that song may have developed
in tandem with dance and in creating
Coalition in human groups so this would
have a really strong evolutionary
pressure right if you want human groups
to be well coordinated you want to be
able to coordinate bodily motion
together you want to encourage things
like shared Rhythm
um synchronizing work and music just
functions as a very efficient way to to
get people in sync in that sense I think
the main takeaway is that we have
evidence that human song is this really
fundamental aspect of the human
experience and is likely shaped by our
biology and human evolution so this is
really something so fundamental to
humanity that also seems to unite Us in
the way that we go about it
[Music]